il faut manger trois fois par jour on a
beau regarder les émissions de cuisine
avoir beaucoup de livres de recettes pas
certain qu'on aime vraiment cuisiner
j'en discute avec stéphanie côté
nutritionniste mère de famille et
collaboratrice à l'émission depuis 18
ans avant la pandémie les québécois
acheté 20 à 30% de leurs aliments à
l'extérieur du foyer ça c'est sans
compter les boîtes report puis le
prêt-à-manger la question que je me pose
c'est est ce qu'on aime vraiment
cuisiner je pense qu'on aime la cuisine
plus que cuisiner si la cuisine un peu
comme on consomme la mode ou la
décoration dans des émissions de télé
dans des magazines dans des vivres ça
peut tellement être beau des belles
images de nourriture mais est-ce qu'on
passe toujours à l'action je suis pas
certaine depuis des années on nous
martèle dans les messages publicitaires
que cuisiner c'est censé être difficile
ou compliqués ou fatigants et qu'on a
besoin de l'aide des deux des produits
du marché pour nous aider parce que
l'industrie nous aurons un peu laver le
cerveau depuis longtemps plaint on
essaye de me convaincre qu'on n'a pas le
temps de cuisiner puis souvent on l'a
démontré à travers les années c'est pas
plus long m quelque chose de congeler ou
faux que de le faire puis ça coûte moins
cher pour contrôler la qualité des
ingrédients pions dont on contrôle le
goût oui pis c'est vrai elle elle la
publicité fait vraiment en sorte que
l'on doive se tourner vers des produits
et du commerce ça semble être la
solution
mais les solutions on lit détient aussi
je pense qu'on manque de confiance ou
s'y connaît un peu fier qu'on a peur de
se tromper de rater notre peau il faut
dire que la barre est haute
parfois quand on voit les photos sur
instagram les images en et magazines ou
à la télé et que la nourriture est
présenté parfois comme des oeuvres d'or
on pense que si ce qu'on doit réaliser
aussi quand on cuisine ça met de la
pression mais pourtant la cuisine de
tous les jours peut être beaucoup plus
simple et on n'a pas à mettre la
pression et la barre aussi haute
parce que si on parle de pression sans
tutoie que les gens ont une pression de
angers santé de manger bio de manger
local est ce que ça ça les frênes
oui d'avoir l'impression qu'il faut tous
être parfait dans tout ça peut
décourager et pourtant l'alimentation ça
ne peut pas être parfait même que c'est
mieux de ne pas essayer de l'aide parce
que quand métro des objectifs trop
élevés puis qu'on veut être parfait mais
ça nous amène peut être avoir une
certaine obsession avec la nourriture
peut-être même une relation malsaine
avec la nourriture c'est soit parce que
ça nous met dans une drôle de position
mental s'est classée c'est plus agréable
cq5 ça devient une tâche un peu ardu oui
ben si ça devient un concours ça devient
un examen chaque fois qu'on prépare à
manger
c'est sûr que le côté plaisir lui il
prend le bord je pense important de
redonner confiance aux gens en leur
capacité à cuisiner à se nourrir à se
préparer un bon repas aussi simple soit
il ce faire une bonne omelette avec une
salade c'est un report ça peut être plus
compliqué que ça il n'ya pas avoir trois
services hors auto pour que ça soit 1 -
le conseil que je donnerais aux gens
c'est essayer pas de suivre une recette
c'est à dire à moins que vous fassiez la
pâte cellou de la boulangerie lost une
science exacte
je peux pas jouer sur les quantités ok
mais tout le reste est un petit peu plus
de ceci un petit peu moins de cela sa
bonne année quelque chose qui est
intéressant de toute façon wii puis s'il
manque un ingrédient c'est pas grave on
peut la faire la recette aussi on peut
changer une sorte de parc pour une autre
on peut mettre ses plus d'une épice mans
et du nôtre donc oui on peut jouer avec
ça beaucoup de personnes ont besoin
d'être accompagnés des prix par la main
parce que peut-être juste parce qu'ils
manquent d'expérience mais à force de
cuisine et on découvre que ça peut être
beaucoup plus simple que l'on pense
qu'on commence à faire cuire des pâtes à
faire griller un poisson à se préparer
une soupe aux lentilles on voit que wow
c'est bien plus facile qu'on pensait et
ça peut-être s'est déclenché quelque
chose parce qu'on a un petit peu de
misère à planifier sur place pour
contrer de la difficulté peut-être que
ça lui tente juste pas de planifier en
fait quand on ne planifie pas souvent ça
nous crée un stress plus tard parce
qu'on veut sauter l'étape de la
planification mais quand un soir de
semaine on arrive à 5 heures le soir
puis on se demande qu'est ce qu'on mange
pour super on ne peut pas penser aux
repas d'avant son ne peut-être pas pensé
avoir une réserve de certains aliments
manger pour pouvoir improviser ça
devient stressant et le plaisir prend le
bord c'est certain donc juste de
planifier un minimum en plus qu'est ce
qu'on va manger cette semaine c'est quoi
les ingrédients que j'avais dans le
garde manger pour pouvoir faire un repas
de dernière minute sans nécessairement
voir tout tout tout planifié d'avancé ça
fait relâcher la pression que ça fait
l'histoire deux semaines de ça devient
un moment où on peut prendre plaisir on
transmet et délits certaines
connaissances aux enfants qui pour eux
ça va servir évidemment plus tard aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on ce chouette le point
dans notre avenir il me dire je nous
souhaite que la cuisine reprennent une
place dans nos habitudes parce que elle
vraiment été tassé au cours des
dernières n'ont seulement deux dernières
années mais dernière génération avec le
fait qu'on peut tout avoir tout préparé
on a perdu beaucoup beaucoup des
compétences culinaires à l'échelle de la
société
donc je souhaite que l'on retrouve la
cuisine et qu'on reprenne du temps pour
cuisiner aussi parce que présentement
c'est pas juste une question de temps au
pass de trois heures par jour devant un
écran une émission de télé ou sur les
réseaux sociaux
je souhaite qu'on se donne du temps un
peu de ce temps là pour cuisiner qu'on
se fasse davantage peut-être confiance
soucis sur nos capacités souhaite que
les gens qui en font déjà beaucoup plus
qu'il se met de la pression mais j'ai
envie de leur dire fait une bonne job
fierté
soyez satisfaits même s'ils sont un peu
moins de réseaux sociaux un peu plus de
deux projets avec les enfants cuisine
c'est tellement simple tout ça merci
beaucoup